ROGER MARTINEZ: One of
the most powerful features
of Google Cloud Compute Engine
is managed instance groups.
So managed instance groups
let you automatically scale
your application out to
handle those peak loads
and automatically heal in case
one of your instances go down.
Today, I'm going to do a quick
dive into managed instance
groups and show you how
easy it is to set one up
for your application.
On Google Cloud,
an instance group
is simply a group
of virtual machines
that can be managed
as a single entity.
A managed instance group
is an instance group
of identical VMs created
based on an identical instance
template.
A managed instance group
introduces a whole bunch
of functionality,
like autoscaling
for increasing the size of your
group depending on the load,
autohealing for
automatically replacing
unhealthy instances, and
multizone deployments
for higher availability.
Before I get into
any of that, let's
review the four
Google Cloud resources
that are associated with
creating a managed instance
group.
First is the instance
group manager.
This represents the managed
instance group itself.
The configuration of a
managed instance group manager
will include whether
the instance group will
be zonal or regional
and, if regional,
which zones to distribute
the instances across.
It'll also include the number
of instances in the group
and specify the second
resource that we
need, the instance template.
The instance template is
essentially the cookie cutter
that the managed instance
group manager will use
to provision VMs in the group.
The instance
template will specify
much of the same
configuration that you
might include in a standalone
instance, like machine
size, disk, networking
settings, and more.
You'll only need one
template, but you
do have the option of
specifying multiple ones so you
can do things like
roll out canary builds
of your applications to only a
subset of your instance group.
Next we have a health check.
A health check is
only required if you
want to enable autohealing
on your instance group.
That's when instances
are automatically
replaced when they repeatedly
fail the health check.
These health checks
are the same ones
a load balancer would
use to direct traffic
to healthy instances.
For managed instance
groups, it's
used to decide whether
the instance needs
to be reprovisioned.
When creating a
health check, you
can choose from five
different protocols,
and you can specify
how rigorous you
want the health check to be by
adjusting the check interval
and thresholds.
If you plan on
using autoscaling,
the last thing you'll need to
have is an autoscaling policy.
The autoscaling policy
has all the configuration
that determines under what
circumstances new instances
will be added to and
removed from the group.
It isn't required for a
managed instance group,
and it can be enabled and
disabled after being added.
Let's take a quick look
at how we can set up
all of these resources and
have a managed instance group
up and running in no time.
In this demonstration, I'll
be working from a new project
with no existing resources.
And I'll have only the Compute
Admin IAM role assigned.
In the Google Cloud
console, you'll
find an instance group
under Compute Engine
in the Navigation menu.
You can create everything you
need for your managed instance
group in one shot by clicking
Create Instance Group.
After giving it a snazzy
name, the first thing
you'll want to do is choose
from these three choices--
stateless managed
instance group,
stateful managed instance group,
or unmanaged instance group.
Stateful and stateless managed
instance groups are similar,
except stateful will
let you preserve disks.
Let's choose a stateless
managed instance group.
The next big choice you
have to make is location.
A zonal managed instance
group will provision VMs
in one single zone and is
fine for most use cases.
But remember that a
regional managed instance
group will improve
your availability
by spreading your instances
across several zones.
When you choose
multiple zones, it'll
let you specify which
zones in that region
you want to distribute
your instances across.
Choose at least three to
maximize availability.
Next, let's specify
an instance template.
If the project doesn't have one,
we can create it right here.
For this example, I'll just
create a simple template
that will create an E2 medium
with a Debian boot disk.
Next, let's add an autoscaling
policy in this section here.
For this demonstration,
I'll leave it
with the default values.
I'll dive deeper into all these
settings, like cooldown period
and scaling controls,
in a later video.
By default, it's going
to use CPU utilization
at 60% as a metric that
it uses to scale up.
But you can adjust
that percentage
or replace the metric
with load balancer
utilization or a Stackdriver
monitoring metric.
If you want, you can also
add additional metrics
by hitting Add New Metric.
There's no one-size-fits-all
configuration here.
It's going to depend on
your application's needs,
but the default values will
work for most use cases.
One thing I will change
is the minimum number
of instances, because
remember, this
is a regional instance group.
So I want to make
sure that I have
at least one instance in each
of the zones that I specified.
Down here at the bottom is
where we configure autohealing
by specifying a health check.
I don't have one yet, so
I'll just create a new one.
The default here is TCP.
If your application needs
something different,
you have the options of these
other protocols in this list.
I'll select HTTP and specify
the request path for the health
page of my web application.
Down here under
Health Criteria is
where we indicate how frequently
the health check should run
and at what point to
consider the state
of an individual
instance as unhealthy.
With these default
values, the health check
will run against each
instance every 10 seconds.
If it doesn't
receive the response
it's looking for in 5 seconds,
it'll count that as a failure.
Three consecutive failures means
the health check state will
be unhealthy and will
only become healthy again
after two consecutive successes.
Once we're done here, we're
ready to create our managed
instance group with
autoscaling and autohealing.
You can click Create
down here or Command Line
to see the corresponding
gcloud commands.
You can see here the four
resources we're created--
the instance template,
the health check,
the instance group
itself, and finally,
the autoscaling policy.
That's a really quick
rundown, but there's plenty
more you can do to get the most
out of your managed instance
groups.
For example, enabling
predictive autoscaling
will feed your instance
groups historical trends
and current load into
machine learning models
so that the autoscaler can
anticipate autoscale events.
This way, the autoscaler
will behave more proactively
and have machines ready to
roll with less time waiting
for machines to initialize.
For more information on
managed instance groups and all
they have to offer,
check out the link
to the documentation below.
In the next video, I'm going
to discuss in more detail how
you can make the most out of
your managed instance groups
by making sure you have an
effective autoscaling policy.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]